[Music]
[Applause]
it's time for our lead guest of Super
Bowl week we wanted to have on a Las
Vegas Legend a pillar of the Vegas
entertainment scene but they were all
too busy and wouldn't get up this
morning so please welcome the great
carrot to
yeah hi buddy very well very well that's
very well carot top is
this is what 18 years uh yes 18 years of
the Luxor yes I was just thinking when
you before your intro that's absolutely
the truth everyone would not come down
here at this hour we like we sleep in at
night and they asked to do it I said
I'll do it I'll do it did you go to bed
last night really late you did I watched
into the Grammys and then I yeah I tried
to pass okay so when you were uh on the
Vegas Yes Vegas scene yes when did you
decide not to kind of indulge in the
Vegas scene I've never honestly have I'm
the biggest nerd in the world I go to I
go in and out the back door and do uh do
the show and go home it's every night
it's 6 nights a week so it's kind of
taxing okay but a lot of comedians
there's always been time for drinking
gambling you hookers and
drugs but that was early on not on a not
on a regular basis not on a regular
basis did you ever have take a week off
did you ever have some rough nights here
yes of course we did well give me an
idea early on probably early on yeah you
wake up you know right around show time
and uh you're like oh rough you know
come out of that pool like you said um
but you try not to have too many NE
nights you know you if you want to be a
pro be herever you got to kind of take
it like a real job because people think
oh you're Vegas you know they always
make funny of you oh you go to work do
an hour an hour night oh boy that's
rough but in reality the show starts in
uh you know 3: in the afternoon getting
ready for it right writing preparing and
then rehearsing and then doing sound
check and the meet and greet and then
the show so you're there from 3: to 11:
when did you realize you could make this
a career just 20 minutes
ago no I swear I don't know it happens
so fast right you just one day you're
you're trying an open mic night and
trying to get in a a gig and then the
next thing you know they're like you're
this is your 18th year at the Luxor so
it goes by fast okay but when did you
decide what your angle was going to be
in entertain oh yeah with the props and
all that yeah I know I uh that's how
always tell young kids you know try to
find your voice and find out what is
going to be your platform I uh had no
idea I went up there and I think my
first joke was a neighborhood crime
watch sign that I had
stolen and uh I walked on stage and I
said sorry I'm late I'm in the
neighborhood and I said how good is
crime watch if they I'm watching their
their
signs and so it was a good it was a good
intro and it was funny one cuz I stolen
it but uh it was also true because it
was true you know how much thievery goes
on in uh in your world a lot yeah yeah
is it sampling like in music it's not
stealing it's sampling you know that's
an interesting question with comedy I
try not to do that I mean be h i mean
there's always something that's a
parallel thought you know I I just came
up with something with the the Chiefs
and the 49ers lot of red lot of red so
it's it's easier to have like you know
TR a trump face and a a Biden face where
where they're both red you know it's
like red red I invented red so um so uh
right I'm mean totally did there wasn't
read before I'd read it wasn't read but
um so he tried to come up with stuff
that's that's not you know everyone's
doing a trump joke you know but I try to
think that might be my my my parallel to
it I don't know people thought both his
big red head face when did you know that
okay I made it oh wow you know maybe
maybe the first Tonight Show you know
where it's something legit you know you
they walk you out and they say you know
you're standing on the gold star where
Johnny Carson stood it's kind of a big
moment where you think okay I might have
I might have I'm not in some bar some
strip club in
Atlanta U you know entertaining topless
girls I'm actually on The Tonight Show
wait you did standup acts at strip clubs
yeah yeah how did that I think every
comic has has done something like that
you don't all start out at the luxur you
don't no okay in The Dan Patrick Show
you don't start out but do people like
yell at you because they want to see the
girls like I got to be honest with you
they hated me I'm at the Gold Club and
all you're yeah please welcome kotp
boo I mean 99% of the time when you hear
a car please welcome Carrot Top a boo
comes out so why is that well because
they don't to see me and I didn't I
didn't want to see me I wanted to I
wanted to see boobs too so that was my
that was my salvation in a sense of
being on uh performing at the at the
strip clubs because I had you know all
my props I'd have a a fake pair of boobs
so I would hold them up like look I got
boobs too you know and so they would
they would let me live another hour
because I would I would say look we're
going to go to boobs now boobs now and
then I would do one of my
jokes and then here's boobs again so you
know the owner owner loved it he's like
I like your creative way of keeping them
from killing
you so yeah I who was your model role
model there oh well well George Carlin
was probably one of the biggest ever um
Richard prior George Carlin gallager
Gallagher was Richard uh Carlin Richard
car George Carlin um was tremendous I
knew him real well yeah he had I was I
remember I was at an airport in
Philadelphia and he walked over to me or
he was walking towards me and I was
walking towards him and I thought ah do
I do it do I am I going to be that guy
you
know do I do it you know so I'm like Mr
Carlin I don't want to bother you but
I'm a I'm a young comic and I just
wanted to say hi and he's like G job and
it was just like this moment where you
have where yeah he's like uh he's like
what are you doing man I said just off
to another gig like you and he said I
love that joke you do that joke with the
paper cups and string God damn it that's
funny and I said I said oh you know
great I'm thinking man he knew my Act
and the joke was a a paper cups and
string telephone you know you'd say hi
what's going on if you I've had it for
years well I back then I said we need an
updated version of the paper cups and
strings so I'd have another cup that
came out for call
waiting so I said hold on I have another
call yeah I got to call you back I'm
call the call
waiting okay it was good and then after
the the call waiting I had three cups
for for conference
calling so it kept growing you know a
joke that can keep growing and then I
had then the punch line was the clear
cup for callor ID like I know it's
you I'm looking right at you thank you
thank you that's thank you I got a good
crowd back there good crowd
there do you laugh at your own jokes um
no I don't think any comic laughs on I
laugh at them laughing at the joke like
if I do if I do a drump thing and they
laugh then I I I laugh sometimes with it
yeah but I don't sit over right J and
just start laughing you know Comics go
oh that's funny but I always feel like
the when a comedian is trying to lead
you that to laugh at my joke because I'm
laughing at my joke right right like
yeah I do that I mean I definitely but
if you're sitting in a room for the
comics they usually every comical go H
that's that's that's the typical
response like ah and that's funny how
you know when you're funny to other
comedians though when you cuz I it's
competition well right away I mean
that's the most brutal audience you can
have so yeah you know you're in the room
of Seinfeld like you just showed earlier
you know talking to best of the best I
don't know is sein best oh the best of
the best yeah nobody's close to sign
well I mean I think it's I mean he's in
the top 10 as far as just the most
classical comic standup you know no
swearing it doesn't go Blue no he's just
he's he's as always say got it you know
he's got it but prior uh was rich prior
was brilliant when Eddie got up there
when Eddie Murphy Eddie Murphy there's
been so many Comics that have just been
I mean you know from the Dave
Chappelle's now to the Chris rocks to
the they're just there's always these
new guys that are they're not even new
they're old like me now but um that are
brilliant I mean you know and that's
what's fun about comedy just like music
and sports it's all it's all different
you know he's a Carrot Top 18th
anniversary of his Las Vegas headlining
residency at Luxor Hotel and Casino
longest running comedy headliner in
Vegas good for you just got yeah look at
that how how is Vegas changed since you
got here that's cuz pen and Teller the
only one talk so they can't they can't
be in the same category cuz we've been
there longer you don't even
talk so I yeah I think how's Vegas
changed oh my god well you know when I
when I first start I felt feel like that
old guy but when I started Vegas in uh U
20 seven eight years ago there was um 10
shows I mean you know there were 10
hotels so you know the MGM Graham wasn't
even built yet so when I started so it
was a there's a joke in the show where I
say your room's not ready and I say are
you cleaning it no we're building it
right now we're finished building it so
so it's in a sense it's true I've seen
I've seen Vegas go you know now we have
the sphere you know the sphere is you
know a billion lights to make the sphere
you know yeah I went to see it yesterday
the Lu are one
one one light we just have one little
light yeah it's all we need yeah I went
to the sphere yesterday did you go check
it out yeah I've not yet seen it I just
beautiful pretty pretty cool pretty cool
uh are you going to the Super Bowl I'm
trying I don't have a ticket yet that's
not why I came with the
show I just I just don't that's a good
thing good way to go it's a it's a good
way to start you know first day of the
week and promoting Ione have a ticket I
can get but I don't have a ticket but
I'm doing a lot of promotion I'm doing a
lot of things I brought you these plants
and I'm doing a lot of things thank you
so I brought you the fire yes the
beautiful fire yeah this never get near
that don't let my okay when did you
decide on the like how long does it take
you to do your hair no
time I mean I think that's pretty
obvious it takes a lot of time no time
just some Sharpies and uh
yeah it is what it is yeah I had a lady
at my show last night say I like your
old wig
better that just made me laugh laugh
made me laugh in two ways like well it's
not a wig too you know but I like the
old wig better yeah I said okay what are
you chewing on a cough drop oh cuz it's
like 4 in the morning thanks so when
when do you know not like being at 4:00
in the morning that freezy gold oh come
on stop you're
soft I am soft I'm a Dolphin fan yeah I
know do the dolphins make you cry like
Dar cry like Darius Rucker they do they
do man every it's always yeah next year
it's not going to be next year did bu
into them did you buy
not day one I wasn't to a fan from day
one and everybody was like oh no dude
I'm like nope he he got hurt in the
Huddle I mean you know it's not easy to
get hurt in the Huddle uh so if anybody
out there would like to take carrat toop
to the game yeah and not the Raiders
game cuz they're not playing this week
so it's got to be yeah some I got
Raiders tickets I don't need Raiders
tickets the Raiders lost in a bye they
didn't do good I'm just trying for
shtick out yeah you're working you're
working I like you're warming up here I
like my favorite one was I played
Detroit and uh you know Ford Field right
so Detroit fordfield they're big they're
a big fan base yeah you know Ford Field
so I said they should CH they should get
rid of the team okay just get rid of the
team and make it a Ford dealership
because they would do so much better
right it really would and uh they like
Boo and
said well go I said and I said I I I saw
your quarterback at uh it was when
Stafford was playing so I said Matthew
St Stafford was at a bar last night I
swore I saw Matthew Stafford so I looked
over I said I think it's Matthew
Stafford so I bought him a drink when I
gave him the drink he looked over he
said thanks and then in nice of him he
re retal he gave me a beer so he threw
me a beer and hit the guy next to me I
said that's Matthew
Stafford I told you I told you that was
Matthew Stafford wow and that doesn't go
over well in Detroit no okay your police
escort's here okay uh so 18th
anniversary
and if you have a ticket you'd like to
take Carrot Top to the Super Bowl I'll
dress nice I won't wear this I'll comb
my hair
no uh the Luxor you've been extended to
20 30 30 yeah how about that no I know
right I'll be dead by them can you last
that long I was going to say no I'll be
dead by them but uh yeah come before I
die it's the come before I die come
before I die to her I like that t like a
ticker you know tick her couldn't be lot
of things could be three more shows uh
Monday through Saturday at 8 Eastern yes
sir it's great to see yeah you you to
all of you guys are great thank you
thank uh Carrot Top everybody thank
thank